jason don congratulations you've made it
into the third round of this competition
we're sending you back to your home
forges to recreate an iconic weapon from
history that weapon is
the scissor
oh god
well good luck bladesmiths
we'll see you in five days
[Music]
uh day one
feels good to be in my own forge
i've never built armor before i've never
shaped sheet metal before
i need a book armor for dummies you know
they don't make it i looked
two bullets i'm making right now are
gonna be for the blade i'm gonna twist
one one way and i'm gonna twist the
other one the other way i just like the
way it looks i almost screwed that up
twisted it the same direction
i'm going up against don
from texas oklahoma always beats texas
i'm not really familiar with a gladiator
scissor but since it is armoring i've
been doing armoring for about 25 years
i'm sure i can overcome any challenges
that come up for it i'm using a coarse
wrought iron combined with high carbon
steel to make a composite welded blade
i have no idea what that came off of
just
part of my 500 pounds of stuff
hey man we're texas we're bigger and
better and our blades are better
today's armor day it's the big
experiment day but it seems like all
week's been an experiment yesterday i
got a pattern cut out i'm gonna try to
get the gauntlet shape today
i have this big piece of pipe so i can
wrap the metal around it i'm just trying
to beat it until it goes where i want it
to
i'm probably doing this the hardest
possible way
so i've got it lined up with my marks
now i'm gonna throw a little tack welds
on each end and then start getting the
seams closer together
and that almost looks like i'm meant to
do it
my
whole gauntlet section is done in three
pieces the only thing i have left to do
is to make sure all the parts fit back
together there's no warps in there that
i can't take out probably had first time
i'm trying to get the main cone put on
it's driving me nuts
there's a slight warp in it
that keeps catching on the inner layer
oh
turn it
all right one more time
i'm trying to get the main cone put on
there's a slight warp in it
it keeps catching on the inner layer
there we go
oh
that was a pain
is billet number three
i have a billet of damascus
i'm not 100 satisfied with it i don't
think it's gonna look the way that i
want
i'm gonna start over with just a
some plain steel i did not want to be
forging on day four
[Music]
i'm going with the w-2
it's going to look good it's going to
have the look that i want and i'm not
going to be wasting any more time
i'm starting to get the blade pretty
close to the shape i want
keeping my measurements in mind let's
get it done
[Music]
even though i don't like the way the
blade looks
performance-wise though i think it's
going to perform just as good as don's
if i lose i guess he just got lucky even
a blind squirrel getting that every once
in a while
all i have left to do is sharpen the
blade
and then do a little bit of testing we
don't want any triple holding this that
would really suck
[Music]
i want to make sure nothing's going to
rattle loose when the judges start
hitting stuff with it that would hurt so
the final test
it rubs on a knuckle slightly but
you have to be honest i didn't even
notice that until afterwards because i
was just having too much fun swinging
and cutting things with it
all right gentlemen this is the
sharpness test to test the sharpness of
your edge i'm going to attack our
sandman here several times see how they
do
jason you're up first are you ready for
this yes sir all right
[Music]
all right
the handle feels really good in my hand
but the shape of your blade not being as
deep a crescent
made it a little bit more difficult to
slash
all in all solid and it's got a good
look
nicely done thank you all right don you
ready i'm ready
[Music]
don i like the way this is set up
tighter around the arm
right here at my hand
my knuckle is just pounding into the
side
you can see it slashed pretty easily on
the arm and then on the forward punch
didn't quite get a slash i was looking
for i'm feeling a little
nervous
it didn't perform like i wanted i think
jason had the edge here his was a more
comfortable fit across the hand all in
all though did the job
thank you next up i'll give you the dug
bladesmiths this is the kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your weapon
will do i will take your scissor and i
will deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy jason you're first you
ready let's do it
[Applause]
first off the minute i put my hand in
your handle it's not
directly in line with my fist so it's
slightly off
but as you can see i can still wield the
weapon the laceration was deep into this
cavity right here so you've got a very
sharp blade the hook you have
penetrated right into the heart on the
backhand draw it lacerates and guts
everything out and disembowel
this ballistics dummy
your weapon sir we'll kill
good job sir thank you
don your turn let's have some fun let's
do this
[Music]
good
jon let's talk about your weapon
what i like about your weapon is that
it's in line with the handle on the
initial cut here it lacerated right
through there and in this backhand hook
your edge is deep to go in here and
right into that cavity
your weapon will kill thank you all
right gentlemen this is the strength
test now the scissor was used in
gladiatorial combat for both attack and
defense now to test the strength and
durability of your weapon we'll clamp
them into our mechanical device here the
blade is going to come down and strike
the armored cuff of your weapon twice
and then your weapon is going to be
launched into this breastplate jason
i've already got yours strapped in so
you ready to go let's do it okay
just the slightest roll
it's not deformed beyond being sharp and
then you can see where the sword came
down and hit it
caused a bit of deformation and then i
think we were pushed just a little
further offline
right in here it looks like it kind of
waffled just a bit but everything is
still tight still sharp nicely done
thank you so don you ready i'm ready
so looking at this i can i'm having a
hard time finding where the sword hit it
and there's one teeny little mark
you know the blade's still tight on that
edge it's still a razor blade there's no
rolling at all very well done it's nice
thank you
[Music]
bladesmiths you've worked very hard to
recreate weapons that we've never seen
here in the forge before however in this
competition there can only be one forged
and fire champion
and that champion is
[Music]
don congratulations you are the fortune
of fire champion yeah
thank you
jason unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut david baker will explain
jason what this came down to was the
strength test it's a gladiator's weapon
it's got to be strong that rolled edge
and the deformation you took from the
hit on the cuff
well that's why we're sending you home
jason please render your scissor
i spent five days making something i've
never made before i went up against a
guy who builds armor quite often i held
my own against him i'm pretty proud of
that fact
i loved every minute of this experience
don congratulations you were the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
that check for 10 grand how do you feel
right now man i feel fantastic it feels
great to be a fortune fire champion
ten thousand dollars i like to get
something nice for my wife we kind of
had a little fun you know making jokes
at each other about texas versus
oklahoma yeah i'm glad to see texas came
out on top
you